scp-682 versus y-909  can the compound derived from scp-3000  the legendary anita shisha be the thing  that finally ends the wretched life of  scp-682  y-909 is the key ingredient in  foundation amnestics and the researchers  discovered a curious thing when it was  added to 682's tank it caused an  increase in the damage that hydrochloric  acid did to the creature's body this  suggested that 682's regenerative  abilities are somehow tied to its  memories of previous damage taken some  researchers proposed taking scp-682  directly to scp-3000 to see if the giant  eel could kill 682 once and for all  however this proposal was soundly  rejected due to too many unpredictable  factors from the risk of transporting  682 to its unpredictable adaptive  response to scp-3000 such as growing to  scp-3000's insane size or stealing in  samnistic abilities